hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
may 16 2022
how's it going man how are you
i am a tale of two cities
tale of red titties over here for old
freckles
um two game sevens this weekend
for the boston sports fan because you
know what the deal is we're always in it
man
oh sorry
um
bad news first the boston bruins lose
to the carolina hurricanes formerly
known as the hartford
whalers
um
i don't know it was a great series it
went seven games and there were games
where we looked like the better team and
then games where they looked like the
better team and it was a pretty
hard-fought series i thought
you know at the end of the day i did
think carolina was
you know faster more skilled better team
or whatever but the fact that we took
him seven games
uh scared the [ __ ] out of him right to
the very end um
you know bruins team showed a lot of
hats so maybe you know
they had a couple of pieces and next
year who knows so uh i was happy i still
have a bruins hoodie on today
and then the good news
your boston celtics
win another playoff series won another
game seven
and advanced past the defending champion
milwaukee bucks
um
yeah you know what i got to be honest
with you i usually get nervous on a game
seven but i saw the look on jason
tatum's face after they went around the
garden they showed all the legends that
were there
um
i remember the last
one they showed we had danny ainge there
but he still works for the team but uh
cedric maxwell cornbread maxwell was
there
from the famous 1981 team get on my back
i'll carry you he was there
um did i see ml car i don't know i had
kids running around me uh trying to get
the game on but um i just saw the look
on tatum's face and i was just like this
guy
is not gonna let us lose and um
i gotta be honest with you how about
grant williams the guy i'm always
talking about who can't get a [ __ ]
call to go his way
first time ever
in his celtic career he was the high
scorer and the man does it in a game
seven to close out the defending
champion milwaukee bucks
um peyton pritchard was big down the
stretch with a bunch of threes al
horford played out of his mind this
series
jaylen brown jaylen brown as always and
um
i don't know man i think uh you know
we got as
good a shot as the heat do i know the
heat always have a good team so i don't
know anything about those guys
but i'm really excited you know what's
it sucks to be all the way out here in
la when the celtics and bruins have a
game seven the atmosphere in boston must
have been great but i will tell you one
of the best things about the celtics
winning another playoff series out here
is right after they win they go to the
local
you know
sports show
that has former laker great michael
cooper on it and he hates the celtics
like no one i've ever seen
and it was so awesome he just would not
give it up
to the celtics he's like oh if they had
middleton dan milton uh yeah they're the
you know bucks win this series and all
this stuff and all he was talking about
was how the bucks blew it he didn't talk
about the incredible game
that the uh
celtics played or the incredible series
that they played
you know i mean if he wants to talk
about blowing something we blew that was
that the game four
we blew that one
um
was it game four was it game three we
had him one of those games
and we let it slip away in the fourth
quarter so i mean i don't know what he
was talking about i just makes me so
happy that he hates the celtics
and knowing that the celtics won
is really bothering him uh
made it even the
he didn't say he didn't say one thing
he's just like oh you know if you're
going to leave him open like that i mean
look at his wide all you can knock that
down all day oh yeah
oh yeah is that how it is michael we'll
see all right so who knows michael
cooper's not happy which means the
celtics fans are
which is awesome we are advancing to the
eastern conference finals
um very excited about that and
the red sox actually won
a series i think we took two out of
three from the rangers i missed it all
the games because i was on the road but
i was keeping track of them
and um
i saw that the yankees finally lost and
so i text versi yesterday i'm like dude
yank last time yankees played they
played
they're playing the orioles today you
got to [ __ ] bury him
you got to put a bet in he goes they
already won today i was like [ __ ] that
was the game
that was the layup
so um
anyways congratulations to boston
celtics and uh
great great year for the uh
for the bruins i definitely think we're
moving in the uh the right direction
we're always in there and i know we lost
in the first round but i'm i'm still
you know
optimistic about the direction that
we're going in and also the fact that
tuka rusk retired
so we had all new blood
in goal i think we're doing all right
all right plowing ahead here um
i am still doing the intermittent
fasting
hitting intermittent fasting i haven't
stepped on the scale i was a buck 82 and
a half last time i got on the scale i'd
like to be 10 pounds lighter
so um i've been doing that and i got to
be honest with you after like two days
you just sort of settle into it
it's not that big a deal
eight hours eating 16 hours of not
eating so like right now
i haven't eaten yet geez my kids are
louder than hell today
um
let's see here
come on now
i have yeah 13 hours 29 minutes oh i
have to go 16 hours so i still have two
and a half hours ago what
oh yeah it's eight in the morning that's
right i can eat around 10.
oh jesus uh but you know what it's been
good for like no late night eating which
is huge especially when you're on the
road you're depressed
you know i miss my wife i miss my kids
um
let's see here uh i guess i could talk
about the
um the friggin uh trip i just had
amazing trip i did sacramento fresno and
oakland california and i went out with
dean delray and he's he's from up there
so
he was excited to get back up there and
we just sort of walked around like every
town
like the first day i i flew up to
sacramento
um
landed day of the show so i kind of
sequestered myself in the hotel room
right
and uh went out did the shows the first
show my god lunatics
lunatics first not lunatics it was just
like three or four lunatics i had a
debate with the guy about tom brady
deflategate this is in sacramento
california
and [ __ ] uh what is it it's in may of
2022.
so
i effortlessly shut him the [ __ ] up once
i told him the whole [ __ ] details of
that goddamn case and then also i asked
him what he was and he was a raiders fan
i'm like oh the raiders what is your
what is your motto if you ain't cheating
you ain't trying shut the [ __ ] up
imagine a raider fan bringing up
cheating just imagine that
oh those [ __ ] babies and they talk
about the tuck rule
and of course oh that that that that
[ __ ] uh roughing the passer in 1977
no [ __ ] problem with that one
that one that helped him go to the super
bowl that and the fact that franco
harris and rocky blyer both went down in
the same game yeah those all those three
they don't
you know none of that [ __ ] no thanks to
the steelers
well that's actually a bad example
that's just an injury but literally [ __ ]
[ __ ] call gave the raiders the game
in 1976 a [ __ ] [ __ ] rule
at least ours was a rule it's a stupid
rule
i don't agree with it i think it's a
[ __ ] fumble and a raider fan will
then say we'll just pinch that part out
there and ignore the roughing the passer
rule anyway
then i was talking about abortion and
some woman brought up uh you know rape
babies
you know
then uh got into that debate and then
then then that topic's on the table and
that's my job now i have to riff about
rape babies thanks a lot
lady acting like you were at the [ __ ]
senate or wherever the hell it is that
they passed laws in this country
and then i had somebody else over on the
uh i don't know what they were
i don't know i'm putting together a new
iron whenever i put together a new hour
i'm like heavily trashing women
i don't know why this happens i think
because i don't have any material i go
into a defensive mode so the old index
finger is pointing at everybody else and
not myself so
you know
it is what it is eventually by the time
i shoot my special i'm pointing more at
myself it becomes a more balanced hour
and 15 minutes but right now i'm gonna
tell you we're a little [ __ ] top
heavy
and this weekend when i go to florida
yes you can look forward to that
although i don't think it's uh
i don't think i'm considered
misogynistic in florida i think i'm
considered wholesome and have ham family
values
i don't know how it works down there i
don't pretend
to understand florida i mean when you're
a state that actually confuses people
when you confuse the rest of the south
when the rest of the south is going hey
you might want to dial it back a little
there i mean you know you're getting
after it
and you know i don't fault the people of
florida
okay if every time i walked out to my
mailbox i have to like look for a body
of water where literally a dinosaur
could come out of it chomp on my leg and
start doing death rolls
as he spins my leg out of my [ __ ] hip
socket
you know
while also [ __ ] up a brand new pair
of
wranglers you know i don't need that
[ __ ]
i don't need that [ __ ] that's just
that's insanity um
by the way uh
condolences you gotta do this every year
to toronto maple leaf fans
somebody sent me the funniest [ __ ]
picture and i j i couldn't post it just
because it's just like maple leaf fans
go through enough you know those two
guys that carry out the cup every year
wearing white gloves
somebody photoshopped the stanley cup
out of the photo and put a golf bag that
was in the toronto maple leafs colors
with the maple leaf insignia
oh my god brutal
by the way
very quietly
because it is
you know
hockey and no one really pays attention
to it very quietly the tampa bay
lightning are going for a three-peat
when was the last time somebody won
three stanley cups in a row well boy boy
howdy i'll tell you
that was when that was the
80 81 82 83 82 83
and he wanted 283 yeah that was the last
time someone won three in a row and that
team actually won four in a row from
1980 to 1983
the new york islanders
with the late great mike bosse
won four in a row
won four in a row but no one has won
three in a row since then there's been
people winning back to back like
edmonton went back to back in 84 85 87
88.
who else the penguins won 91-92
detroit won like 97 98
then it gets foggy for me
brain gets older and i don't remember i
want to say the penguins
did they go back to back in the 2000s or
2000 teens i can't remember
i don't know but it's been a while it's
been a long [ __ ] time since since old
freckles was 15 years old
since the last time somebody won three
stanley cups in a row and i gotta tell
you
now that the maple leafs because once
the bruins lose i root for the [ __ ]
maple leafs
you know what i mean you got to do it
they're the greatest fans in sports and
i don't think you can argue it
considering i'm going to be 54 years old
next month and the the [ __ ] maple
leafs have not won it in my lifetime
and
these guys are like
still selling out every single game and
it's the hardest ticket to get
um
you have to literally go up there and go
scalp tickets i know somebody you know
that was working for the nhl network and
i said hey i'm in toronto can you get me
tickets he goes dude i have i have a
hookup with every single city except
that one you can't get it even the nhl
can't get them you got to stand outside
and scalp tickets i mean
you would think that they would they
were winning a cup every other year out
there
54 years this is what fascinates me
is
the rangers
their drought was from 1940
to 1994. that was 54 years and people
were chanting 1940 at them and making
t-shirt islander fans and all of them
were doing that just torturing them
and i'll show you how the this is why
canada has the reputation
for being for the perception of being
nice is nobody is chanting
1967 adam is it because it's a 1967
if it was 1970
see if it had but that that 1955
but didn't even chant that to the
[ __ ] uh
the red wins and the red wings went 65
70 and they were in like 42 years or
whatever
what i'm saying right now what do you
guys think is is like a
like you're cursed how many years at
this point
i think you gotta you gotta go half a
cent when there's 30 [ __ ] teams
or like say like the nfl there's 32
[ __ ] teams
so if you win one once every three
decades you're kind you're average
that's average once every three decades
so you'd have to go at least 50 years
before anybody could say you're [ __ ]
cursed nobody even says the browns are
cursed
there's no
story there's no billy goat there's no
[ __ ] you know they they sold
jim brown to go [ __ ] you know make a
musical down there in uh toledo nothing
nothing
it's just they have not won
they won an nfl title in 1965 i want to
say 64 or 65.
and i got to be honest with you i count
that [ __ ] thing
this whole thing where you don't count
championships until super bowls is the
stupidest [ __ ] thing ever so you're
telling me jim brown
auto grammy telling me these guys
weren't champions
yeah the [ __ ] out of you
you know but the [ __ ]
you know yankees and and and [ __ ] uh
canadians can count
titles all the way back to 100 years
over 100 years ago with the canadians
it doesn't make any sense to me
i always just found it weird
well bill we realized that because you
brought it up 9 000 times all right well
until people start walking around saying
the green bay packers are the [ __ ]
yankees canadians celtics and [ __ ] uh
patriots no i can't say patriot steelers
that's the same [ __ ]
sport yeah that that that the packers
are yeah they're the greatest
they've won like four super bowls in
like 11 nfl titles i mean what the f i
mean they've won in every [ __ ] era
um
all right sorry i've got my getting my
period here let me just let's talk about
some fun [ __ ] um so the next day after
we um
after i do my rape baby early show and
then the second show they were just it
was [ __ ] butter man it was amazing
both shows were awesome but the second
show
was incredible so i'm walking around
sacramento a city that really gets a bad
reputation
you know i'm not gonna lie to you i went
by two bail bonds
you know
offices in a scientology building in
like [ __ ] three blocks it's just like
wow you can get into all kinds of [ __ ]
all kinds of [ __ ] out here by the way
scientology does it does i don't know am
i out of my mind i feel like it gets
more [ __ ] than it deserves
you know what you guys do if i see you
found out i secretly joined
no i think it gets more [ __ ] than it
deserves
you know for as [ __ ] up as they say it
is for as culty as it is i got one
question where are the bodies
where are they i mean i'm just saying
it's like a sports fan i need to see the
hardware
as a former catholic i mean we got
bodies stacked up
we got pedophilia we got we got torture
we have crusades well what do they got
a little mind control
a couple of [ __ ]
disgruntled sitcoms stars i i just don't
see
i don't see it
it's like people trash in russia can you
believe they invaded that country yeah
that's what powerful countries do you
haven't noticed that
[Laughter]
don't you see a similarity in what
they're doing and possibly maybe another
country that you might know a little
better might have done
um
not condoning
not condoning any of that by the way um
so we ended up the next day
we were driving down to fresno so i had
a nice morning
um
and i found this uh
pipe and tobacco store
that was right next to the original
tower records in the tower section which
i had never been to
in sacramento
so we went down there i got a coffee i
became a coffee drinker somehow when
make while making this movie
every once in a while
i'll tell you know when you're old when
you find one pistachio in the pocket of
your sweatpants
i mean tell me that's not some old man
[ __ ]
yeah i'll shave this for later
um i don't i mean i know my kids don't
eat pistachios cause i can't blame them
like they dropped it on the floor and i
picked it up
um anyway
um
yeah kind of became a coffee drinker and
actually really like it now
what do i go with i go with the
cappuccino
i get excited if they do the little uh
design
and my goal as a new coffee drinker is
i'm never going to have a cup of
starbucks
just not i think it was a good idea it
just [ __ ] got out of control i just
look at them like they have to be like
the burger king
of like coffee you know what i mean
not knocking a you know
a burger burger king but you know if
there's a
better one a mom-and-pop one
around the corner
like i went to uh what was it i went to
fulton street coffee
in fresno
and had an absolutely delicious cup of
coffee i forget what the name of the
place where i got the coffee
was in
sacramento but actually i went to
sacramento me and dean i got bought a
little cigar
and i had the [ __ ]
the cappuccino so you know i was flying
right [ __ ]
caffeine and tobacco i'm walking down
like one of those little side streets
in the tower section they had all these
great houses great neighborhood
a couple of classic cars dean posted the
bottom was to see there was a studer
baker there was a first generation f-100
um the front end before the sanford and
sun front end
um so a late 40s ford
and there was one other one i can't
remember what it was uh it was a dodge
i think it was a dodge or something like
that
um but we walked up just
incredibly peaceful street
houses perfect little size like original
ones you could tell like mid-century
ones i think
um no mid-centuries those weird-looking
ones
the brady bunch style house it wasn't
like that it was like before that
just sat there like you know
you know talking about comedy and
all of this [ __ ]
and dean telling me about living up that
way and i just smoking a cigar had a
great time and
ubered back it's funny we got the same
uber driver both ways
and then we cruise down to fresno
fresno which is
one of my favorite [ __ ] cities
um
[Music]
it's i don't know i just like it it's a
great pop level of population downtown
is not like
you know it's quiet and i know they go
through their struggles i know they've
got all kinds of [ __ ] going on up there
but it's still really good people up
there
um i took a picture of this
i posted on my stories this incredible
mural up there
it just said fresno
almost looked like a stamp or something
like that and then within the letters it
had like
you know the uh that classic theater
that i always want to call the uh
the warner theater or something like
that i think that's what it was
it was right next to that fulton street
coffee
but um and i played a theater there i
remember a long time ago i got to find
out which one i played but i know
kennison played that one but i was at a
different venue but anyway we went to
the cvs right next door to it right
there's a couple of homeless people
[ __ ] sleeping out front and some guys
standing there right
typical one of these [ __ ] cities
that is just like
america's kind of turning a blind eye to
right but great people right
so we [ __ ] go in there and i'll tell
you when you get a city that starts
struggling financially even when you go
into the chain they don't get to bet the
same [ __ ] i go into the cvs to go buy
some some [ __ ]
vitamin c gummies
they don't have the 500 milligrams they
don't have the 750 they're only giving
them 250.
250 milligrams i buy them and i eat them
and they taste [ __ ] weird there's
just something about them they were uh
gummies
and dean tried to cut back those things
taste weird right go yeah i go i go
that's fresno that's fresno vitamin c
there's something going on there
i feel like they don't want this city to
make it
so uh
i left it on the table
at the coffee place i figured some
homeless guy could come by and grab it
so he doesn't get scurvy
um
then we walked we walked back to the
hotel we went to a a minor league
ballpark where leonard skynyrd was
playing so they had their whole [ __ ]
um
stage was set up and all that it was
[ __ ] awesome
and uh and then we went by a pawn shop
and they had an entry-level sonar kit in
the window
and then they also had a um
they had one of those apollo three-speed
bikes
from when i was a kid with the the slick
on the back and the smaller tire on the
front
it was in 1968 which was the year i was
born guy wanted way too much money for
it they're going for like six seven
hundred bucks the guy wanted like do you
think two grand
which is so funny like two grand for
that and then you just go on ebay it's
like that's funny this one's 675 bucks
and it's in better condition
um
but anyway so
and once again i got a coffee there had
the uh
oh no that was fresno yeah that was
fresno that was the next day that was
the second day and we just walked all
around there
looking at the architecture and all of
it it just looked like
what a city looked like when i was a kid
in the early 70s and i mean that in a
good way and um
i'm gonna call my agent at some point i
would love to do a run there like the
warner theater
go to a minor league game
and uh
you know maybe finally go to yosemite
after that
maybe bring the kids up and everybody
everybody can go over there
that could be really cool um and then
the last day
we went to uh
we did the oracle in oakland where the
golden state warriors used to play and
all these amazing bands
had performed there and i was thinking
of all the basketball players i saw when
i was growing up knowing they all played
in there
you know dr j larry magic michael
sydney moncrieff
tree rollins
moses malone
george girvin
daryl dawkins mo cheeks andrew tony that
great [ __ ] team
world be free
jack sigma
rick roby
eric ferdstein i'm going really super
obscure here
orlando woolwich i haven't named one
warrior yet
um dare i say will chamberlain maybe
back towards the end of his career when
he played for the lakers
all of those guys with their short
shorts were in there
playing above the rim
um
i think the 74 and 76
championship teams were one in that
building
and then every [ __ ] band
every band the speed metal scene started
up that way and all of those bands ended
up headlining that place and then all
freckles are there i tell you what's
really cool about that place
is um
they have a hole in the wall
dirk nowitzki after a playoff loss to
golden state
uh picked up a [ __ ] trash can and i
swear to god threw it like 30 feet in
the [ __ ] air and put a hole in the
wall up there and they put a piece of
hard plastic over it and then they put
like one of the the uh nba final
t-shirts that the uh
the fans wore
um right above it to sort of mark the
year that it was i thought that was
really cool
um
dirk nowitzki a champion himself
for the dallas mavericks
um mark aguirre
played in that building
isaiah thomas
thomas thomas
bill lambie
mark mchorn
vinnie johnson
scotty pippen
all right bill
we get it dominique wilkins
david thompson
all right
i don't know why
downtown freddie brown dennis johnson
um
there's some like 52 year old right now
going yeah i had that poster
um
and we got to play it but before we went
there we actually went to oakland and
all the years i was doing stand-up i
always played san francisco and i never
played out in oakland oakland was more
the uh
black comedian circuit
and white guys went to san francisco
that's how it was
it was segregated and i never [ __ ]
walked around oakland
and uh i was there in downtown oakland
and i absolutely [ __ ] loved it i went
down i got some barbecue [ __ ] up by
getting the hots the hottest version of
it i was thinking that for some reason
they would they were going to have it on
the side and they didn't they just took
a paint roll and put it all over all of
it but i toughed it up
had some delicious brisket ribs and
chicken went with the three three meat
platter
couldn't finish it dropped it off for
the homeless
um should have left a vitamin water
for him but i had a great time there and
then we went out we did the oracle um
could not have had a better time shout
out to gretchen fellow masshole treating
us right
got me some cigars and afterwards they
had a private room in there with a
metallica pinball machine
and then you walked into like this
speakease and you could like smoke a
cigar in the oracle it was amazing the
crowd was amazing all the crowds
throughout that whole tour was just
[ __ ] awesome
and um
[Music]
i already miss it like i want to go back
there and i was just telling
uh my wife how i wanted to maybe go up
there
and uh maybe stay in san francisco i'd
do some punchline gigs
then we could go over the bridge into
oakland and check out what's going on
over there because i know
i don't know all the nerds bought up san
francisco so all the [ __ ]
white people on the line had to move
into oakland which pushed the black
people you know it always [ __ ]
happens
it's so stupid
i don't understand it i was actually
joking on stage that
the white people that got pushed out of
san francisco should hire
the homeless as hitmen
to kill the nerds and every day if they
got to bring three heads or three nerd
heads
over the bridge
and then they get their stipend
and once you clear out enough of them or
the nerds get the message to stop buying
the silicon valley then they can move
back and then oakland can be what it was
i'm pitching that knowing nothing about
that part of the country all right let
me read um
let me read some uh advertising here for
this week all right look who it is
everybody it's old policy genius
reshopping your home and auto service
with policy genius could lead to savings
that can put
that can put toward
that you can put towards your next home
reno
i love reno oh renovation that's what
they mean or do it yourself project if
your policy is up for new renewal or
your rates go up policy genius can help
you find a lower rate how it works
policy genius is your one-stop shop to
find and buy the insurance you need head
to policygenius.com to get started
policy genes will show you the price
estimates for policies that fit your
search
uh if you like what they find they'll
get you switched over for free
customers who bundled their home and
auto policies with policy genius saved
an average of one thousand two hundred
fifty dollars per year over what they
were paying
uh the team and policy genius are on
hand at every step to help you make
decisions with confidence the policy
genius team works for you not the
insurance company policy genius doesn't
add on to extra taxes policy genius
doesn't sell your info to a third to
third parties policy genius in case you
forgot who they were has earned
thousands of five star reviews across
google and trust pilot
head to
policygenius.com to get your
free
home insurance quotes and see how much
you could save
all right look who it is everybody sorry
i had to take a swig of water there um
water
oh look who it is everybody
um
do me undies
me undies
no more sweaty balls
do me undies be undies you can wear them
right through the fall
too many nerds went into san fran
even though i know they don't call you i
didn't say friend
hire a couple homeless if you can to cut
their heads off so you can move back and
everybody resettles
and drinks some coffee
and leaves a couple love [ __ ] stains all
right me undies i love going up to san
francisco and calling it san fran
they're like nobody calls it here they
call it frisco it's either that way or
the other way around
um no one cares what you call it all
right
frisco
as bad as frisco is nothing is worse
than the land
for cleveland
the land
the berg all those rust belt cities just
struggling still looking for an identity
they used to have one
right hard hat guys [ __ ] you know
welding [ __ ] together
and now it's people making apps all
right
me undies you know
you know
you know those days when your coffee
shop is out of cold brew when your air
conditioner breaks
and you try to go to the beach but
there's zero parking spots yeah life can
be hard good thing me undies is here to
help you take a break from the hardships
of the world and give yourself a soft
summer the summer's here everybody
enjoy it while it lasts before someday
it's too [ __ ] hot to go outside when
you're cocooned in the softest most
breathable undies loungewear and
swimwear known to humanity all your pr
all your other problems will simply melt
away let's face it summer is sweaty
but your butt doesn't have to be with me
undies light and breathable micro modal
fabric
you can stay comfy and cool all summer
long
these are the global warming joints
they have super fun seasonal prints and
tons of styles to choose from sizes and
extra small
to 4xl
so if you can see your dick too much or
not enough they got you covered so you
can break the bring the beach to your
butt without ever leaving your living
room
um if you do dare to brave the heat and
venture to the pool or beach check out
their new and improved swimmer styles
they're soft stretchy and sustainably
made make it a soft summer with me
undies me undies has a great offer to
for my listeners
um for any first-time purchasers you get
up to 15 off if you sign up for for
their free to join membership you can
apply that 15 off to their already
discounted membership prices to get 15
off your first order and 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
that's meundies.com
all right the next one who do we got
here oh look who it is people it's
simply safe simply safe i don't know why
you guys don't have it in this economy
these burglars are getting pretty
goddamn bolts um you guys know i love
the break-in protection that my simply
safe home security system gives me but
it's not always outside forces that you
need
simply saves protection from uh this is
joshua's story
this is his story
everybody listen believe joshua a simply
safe customer from indiana
a few months ago oh a few months ago he
fell asleep with pizza rolls still in
the oven
i you know i've read this like three
times what in the [ __ ] is a pizza roll
it sounds to me like you're just eating
dough
but he has it in the oven does that mean
he like took it out too soon
pizza
rolls
frozen i'm guessing that's what he had
oh [ __ ]
those are like hot pockets with pizza
filling
wow
i'm gonna guess this guy has a lot of
sodium in his diet
um
he fell asleep with pizza rolls still in
the oven
this could have been disastrous yeah he
could have burned him thousands of
dollars in damage to his kitchen and
home or worse luckily joshua believe
joshua has a comprehensive simply safe
system
oh my god i mean if you died because you
fell asleep
and your [ __ ] pizza rolls caught on
fire i mean
that's one of those funerals where you
know everybody's looking at the ground
mostly because they're sad but there's a
few people trying not to look and make
eye contact with somebody else and start
laughing
anyway equipped with everything to
prevent break-ins and smoke detectors to
sniff out fires that's the thing he got
the comprehensive system so he was also
protect protected oh i'm getting a note
from offstage from the lovely nia
okay beautiful is that good that's great
i like how you brought the letter in and
then started talking
hey your hair looks beautiful by the way
whoever did it thank you all right i'll
see you all right luckily joshua has a
comprehensive simply safe system
equipped with everything to prevent
break-ins and smoke detectors to sniff
out fires he start he was started awake
to the sound of a 95 decibel alarm
yeah and those pizza pockets exploding
from his simply safe base station
seconds later he got a call from simply
safe from a simply safe professional
monitoring the pizza rolls didn't make
it but joshua did and i'm sure there's a
lot of people that love joshua believe
joshua
he believes simply safe probably saved
his life that night i also believe he
should stop late night snacking uh
protecting people with a guard is you
know when you almost die from it maybe
that's a time to [ __ ] have a water
and go to bed protecting people when
their guard is down is just one of the
reasons more than four million people
use and love simply safe with the
comprehensive simply safe system and 24
7 professional monitoring you're you
always have someone looking out for you
plans cost under a dollar a day with no
long-term uh contracts or hidden fees
ever you can customize the perfect
system
for your home in just a few minutes at
simply safe.com
go to
today go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com you know what that
reminds me of
um somebody hit the fire alarm when i
was in oakland
there was a party going on right there
in the in the in the um
in the lobby
somebody was getting married and then
there was like a
whole bunch of guys on motorcycles doing
like donuts and revving the engines and
everything was pretty [ __ ] cool
so all of a sudden
you know i'm starting to fall asleep
you know
i'm like joshua except i don't have
pizza rolls in the oven
and all of a sudden
it's just this disgusting
[ __ ] noise when
[Music]
it's at the place there's been a fire
detected within the building please
evacuate please use the staircase
it did it [ __ ] the whole time
it wouldn't stop
so
i call club soda kenny i'm like is this
legit he's like i called downstairs they
said there's a fire on the second floor
and i'm like all right
and we [ __ ]
go out in the stairs you touch it please
this is not a [ __ ] drill you're going
to use the stairs so we go there and
there's like
i don't know everybody in the hotel is
walking down the same staircase and
there's like old people and we keep
having to stop on the stairs there's
like a traffic jam of people going down
the stairs and i just kept looking down
the stairway stairwell looking for smoke
because i'm like if this fire is getting
out of control
how slowly we're going down here at some
point we're gonna have to make a
decision to trample the elderly to get
out of here i always thought back in the
day oh this staircase right there i will
say this if you're high enough up
there's gonna be
traffic
because people who are physically
compromised bill why couldn't you pick
up an elderly person and run with them
that's what i would like to think that i
would do it all depends on how close the
flames are
right
that would be the deal anyway we get
like we walk from the 10th floor it's
one of these places where you got to
watch two flights to get down to the
next floor so we went from the 10th
floor all the way down to the fourth
floor and then they just go
attention please the emergency is over
you can go back to your room and then
everybody on the stairs is just like oh
what the [ __ ] it's just like hey we
didn't burn to death
i was kind of thinking because the
sprinklers weren't on
that we were gonna be
okay um and that's my fire story you
know what
thank god that hotel had simply safe
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e.com
all right solo stove everybody
solo stove you know there's nothing
quite like the feeling of gathering
around a warm fire on a cool evening and
a smokeless fire pit from solo stove
makes your outdoor moments even more
memorable because instead of having to
constantly dodge those goddamn campfire
fumes
you can sit back relax and actually
enjoy the fire it's anything better than
a fire outside
sitting out there feeling its warmth the
only thing that sucks is when the wind
changes and now it's like you're behind
a city bus
a fleet of city buses well no more of
that with the solo stove and right now
you can get a great deal on a solar
stove fire pit upgrade your backyard
with solo with the solo stove fire pit
and the greatest thing too is this thing
is is uh
you can you can you can take it with you
whatever they call it compact or some
[ __ ] right you can bring it to a
tailgate
it's the perfect catalyst for getting
outside and spending more time with
family and friends you can bring it
camping no more trying to [ __ ] get a
piece of flint
can you start a
fire out in the wild yes i can with my
solo stove fire pit
did i mention they're brilliantly
engineered made from premium grade
304 stainless steel not that 303 [ __ ]
that they've been shoving down your
throat
and a 360 degree airflow system that
maximizes efficiency while minimizing
smoke easy to light with a few bits of
starter your fire is blazing a minute
perfectly portable that's what the word
is
not compactable
portable take solo stove with you on
camping trips and more hey do you got
season tickets to the [ __ ]
green bay packers are you sick of
freezing your ass off up there get a
solo stove
shop now and get up to 30 percent off
fire pits all month long and use promo
code bur at checkout to get an extra 10
off plus a lifetime warranty and free
30-day returns just go to solostove.com
and remember you get ten dollars off
when you use promo code burr
all right who do we got here
the lastly but not leastly before we go
into questions the first one being about
intermittent fasting all birds everybody
you know
all birds create shoes and clothing that
are better for you and better for the
planet using a revolutionary uh
roster of premium natural materials
materials like their popular tree runner
sneaker
why is it called the tree runner you ask
because it's made from eucalyptus tree
fiber a lightweight breathable and silky
soft material making the tree run of the
perfect everyday shoe
for getting the most out of sunny days
i'm gonna get a pair of these and let
you guys know how they are
made with premium natural materials like
eucalyptus fiber designed with a
breathable knit that keeps your feet
cool when you're soaking up the sun and
they're super lightweight making them
the perfect pair to take along on any
adventure minimal and versatile
for effortless
everyday style thoughtfully designed
without any unnecessary frills or logos
and they go
uh to go with every outfit find your new
favorite shoes for sunny days and
upcoming travel at allbirds.com
dot-com
sorry all right
what do we got here somebody wants to
talk about
intermittent fasting
something that i've been doing let me
see how many days i've been doing this
[ __ ]
i'll let you guys know i should go step
on the scale
and see if i've lost any weight here i
must have i've been doing it
i did it one two three four five six
seven 8 9
10
11 12. since since um
may 6th
well may 5th is when i started
um i've done at least 16 hours
occasionally a little over 17
every single day except
um
sunday night the eighth
but i've done it one two three four five
six
seven days in a row
i had a day off and then one two three
three days and all this looks like a
[ __ ] baseball schedule
um
and yeah my stomach is going down i'm
hitting the gym after this
and then i'm gonna have uh have a little
bit of lunch here i'll let you know how
it's going
um intermittent fasting um hello mr burr
oh by the way um now that i'm into the
wonderful world of coffee i want you
guys all these cities i go to you tell
me the [ __ ] best cup of coffee and
i'm going to [ __ ] swing by and check
it out i'm going to florida i'm in tampa
so you know i got to go down to ebor
city to get me a cigar or something
uh let me know
what the place is out there um all right
intermittent fasting
hello mr burr
i'm just trying to tell you that
intermittent intermittent fasting
actually works
well good fantastic
he goes i became a fat [ __ ] during the
early days of the pandemic i'm six feet
and was a little over 225 pounds
driving down the road one day i hit a
pothole and felt my titty jiggle oh no
uh and that was the motivation i needed
to get my uh to get to work on myself
well that's good man at some point you
got to be ashamed of yourself to turn it
around
and there's nothing wrong with being
ashamed of yourself if you're ashamed of
yourself that no that means that you
know you can do better
which means you got some pride buried
underneath all that bacon fat uh started
running until gyms open and then got
into cardio and weights no matter what i
couldn't get under 208 pounds then i
tried intermittent fasting and from
august to my birthday in late november
the pounds melted off me my goal was to
be under 190 pounds by my birthday on
november 25th and i hit my goal weighing
in at
189.4 pounds that's [ __ ] awesome he
goes i did 17 hours no eating and seven
hours eating during the 17 hours with no
calories it was all water or tea i was
determined um
and got her done
um at 42 years old i'm healthier than
ever
um
i've ever been and never going back to
being jiggly tits yeah and you drive a
truck too man so i mean that's obviously
a lot of sitting down and not uh
you know eating well
i remember when i was living the life of
a trucker when i was doing college gigs
and all that my my go-to place was
[ __ ] subway
um i told you all that [ __ ] i get a
large stack of pancakes and try to go
the whole [ __ ] day and then i get a
six-inch subway sandwich at the end of
the day hopefully this college paid me
anyway can't wait to see your shows in
toronto in august and windsor in october
and really hope my leafs don't crap out
yet again my heart can't take much more
of their shenanigans
uh
[Music]
that's awesome man i'm hoping this
intermittent fasting is going to get me
down to my goal of a buck 72
uh in or around my birthday i think i
waited too long
um
i don't know we'll see we'll see where
i'm at
i'll keep you guys posted uh
tell me where are you from billy boy
billy boy tell me where are you from
charming billy
um what songs
he's a young boy that wants to go with
scouting like a scout all right where
are you from bill
hey billy boy od
oh d
that's o d e e
um not sure if you saw
saw it floating around twitter but there
was an article written by a guy who said
it's racist when people ask where he's
from
why i ask people where they're from all
the time if they have an accent because
the rest of the world interests me
anyways he says uh i'm a pakistani born
american and i drive uber lyft and
anything else they'll let me i love it
when people ask me where i'm from
because it makes me and my country more
human to them
uh how many pakistani people do you know
um
one
and then there's a couple others that i
might know but i'm not going to ask them
um
what they are because then they'll you
know
if they're indian or they're not
pakistani you know you guys are like
[ __ ] you know michigan and ohio state
i don't want to start that [ __ ] up
uh and you're in a fairly diverse city
exactly bill probably only a few if any
so that's why i love it i don't like how
you just [ __ ] assumed that [ __ ]
even though you were right uh sometimes
i just say one of those countries that
gets bombed a lot some laugh some
apologize on behalf of their army so i
well we're not bombing you guys
i thought that was india i don't want to
start it up i know you guys are
problem is is people in pakistan in
india they just they're they're led
zeppelin fans all right and then
zeppelin wrote that song cashmere and
then that just started the whole [ __ ] up
again as far as i know that's what's
going on over there
um so i asked
so i say ask me where i'm from and don't
worry about the occasional insecure guy
who doesn't like to hear it thank you
for all the laughter well yeah i mean
it's kind of like
it's probably because they got treated
like [ __ ] i mean there's a difference
between like hey man where you from
that's a cool accent as like you know as
being like
dude where the [ __ ] are you from i mean
that's not a good one
all right remedies
uh hey billy drum solo king
someone wrote in
about home remedies i married a black
woman who's a bit older than me
but her mom is from the generation of
home remedies earaches take a bottle of
sweet oil
warm it up under running water
and what do you do with it do you drink
it or pour it in your ear i wouldn't
think you want to pour it in your ear
uh when warm oh here we go when warm not
hot pour a capful in your ear
what
sore throat gargle with peroxide and
water
there are countless others but these are
a few enjoy this summer
with the family in the playoffs peroxide
in water i think donald trump thought
that cured covet
um
all right i would say uh
do i have any [ __ ] home
remedies
no i was i was the vicks vaporub
generation when you had a cold you took
that [ __ ]
and you just rubbed it on your chest
yeah and you smelt like a [ __ ] stick
of wintergreen gum
didn't work
um
there was another one you put a towel
over your head
in your stat you you sat above steaming
water to try to clear out your nasal
passages
but um
i just know other ones like if you're in
the shower if you're taking a shower the
end of a hot shower if you turn it on
and turn it on cold
um
it sucks but once you get used to it
you i can't even tell you how [ __ ]
alive you feel i know a hot shower is
great but i'm telling you when you go
the other way at the end of it there's
something about it it just it [ __ ]
gives you a jolt of adrenaline i feel
way more awake when i do it
but please keep the home remedies coming
here um
here's i would love one um when you get
a sore throat
from screaming [ __ ] jokes
um
mexican hiccup remedies hey there billy
burrito recently a listener emailed uh
you talking about old family remedies
and reminded me of one that i still hold
true to this day it was passed down to
me by my mother
and to her mother and so on first of all
i was born and raised in mexico and i
now live in miami um you know what's
funny um there's a uh
a farmer that i that i'm following
growing his own food
on uh instagram
i'll tweet it out you guys should check
it out it's inspiring me
to uh i always wanted to have like a
home garden i mean i've had like you
know tomato plants out here and stuff
like that but have it like you know like
lettuce and all of that type of stuff
because they're saying once again
they're changing the laws so they they
don't have to write gmos when they're in
your food or whatever if you give a [ __ ]
about something like that um it's
interesting anyway first of all i was
born and raised in mexico and i now live
in miami
uh my mom's side of the family is
completely mexican and as i'm sure you
know us mexican loves love limes
and we also love drinking
i mean what's the hate about that
um so the remedy is for the for the
hiccups it works a hundred percent of
the time if you help it a bit
what
what do you mean help it okay when you
have the hiccups get a lime
slice it in half
grab one half and pour some in
worcestershire sauce on it had to google
how to spell that in mexico
we call it salsa
in glace
english sauce
oh all right
and then just
bite into the half lime with the
worcestershire sour sauce on it
it's going to be super sour and intense
but all that flavor sort of shocks your
body and will sort of forget about the
hiccups
so you scare yourself with flavor just
bite into the lime and swallow all the
lime juice
with the worcestershire sauce on it
um you might
get the need to hiccup again but just
fight it a bit and your hiccups will be
gone i do this whenever i have the
hiccups and it's never failed me
that's [ __ ] wild i want to keep
exploring this because i know somebody's
going to have like some [ __ ] cures
that work who this is like conspiracy
theory
then who knows
maybe you don't have to go to the cvs in
fresno where they have the funny taste
and [ __ ] uh
you know the funny tasting [ __ ]
vitamin c
gummies um anyway love everything you do
i've been a fan since i was 15. i'm 28
now wow i saw you in hollywood florida
florida when you came down in 2021 and
absolutely killed it hope to see you
again soon well that's awesome man thank
you so much
that's always cool
when somebody who's not white likes me
you know you're like all right
my [ __ ] jokes are crossing racial lines
i love it
all right underrated
uh working with people
who know the next step
you don't have to ask for the hammer or
reach for the next piece of plywood
it doesn't matter what you're doing if
the person you're working with can
handle doing what they're doing and also
seeing the project as a whole
i'm writing this because i'm currently
experiencing that unlike the last dumbo
who slowed me down so much that i missed
my own anniversary dinner to meet a
contractual deadline
now wait a minute you're blaming the
person who hands you the [ __ ]
i don't know you should have been
cracking the whip a little [ __ ] hard
is that politically incorrect as a white
person to use that [ __ ] expression
let's see let's look that up we'll end
the podcast on that is it passe
i do know as a white person you wouldn't
want to say that to a black person i can
pretty much guess that all right
um
you guys don't start stepping it up
you're gonna make me have to start
cracking the whip excuse me
all right
cracking
the whip
i mean i don't even need to be origin or
maybe it's a horse racing thing we'll
see origin
come on
oh i have the slowest internet crack the
whip
an expression for using one's authority
to to urge subordinates to work harder
or behave better crack the whip traces
its origins to the 17th century
horse-drawn wagon drivers
according to the american heritage
dictionary of idioms
uh
cracking the whip racism claim fails
cracking the whip is not a racial term
um
i love when white people do that [ __ ]
actually it's not a racial term even it
reminds you of slavery
so i'm going to continue saying it while
i do the tomahawk job
just because that's what human beings do
you can't tell me what to do
um i'm gonna take it to a to that level
um anyway
that is the podcast ladies and gentlemen
the celtics move on the red sox win a
[ __ ] series for the first time since
april i believe
uh the yankees
i feel like lost the game for the first
time since april
um they're absolutely killing it and the
[ __ ] [ __ ] talking blue jays are just
sitting in the middle of the pack
this is the movie
huh
this looks like one of those three star
movies that you can wait until it goes
to home video until it goes to
blockbuster we'll see though
um
anyway the bruins the bruins go home for
this for the goddamn summer oh well
whatever you can't have everything
um
all right that's it i almost said you
can't have your cake and eat it i was
like wait was that a reference to
slavery you know that was a cakewalk
i mean you how do you even keep up to it
it's so funny like how many [ __ ]
sayings came out of slavery that stuck
around
you know
there weren't any slaves up north we
didn't come around we didn't come up
with any sayings
ah dude this is gonna be like a tea
party
that's when you
it came from throwing people's lawn
furniture over the [ __ ] uh
the back railing of a porch or something
and it's a reference to it i don't
[ __ ] know what it is all right that's
it go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll check in
on you on thursday